meine damen und herren ganz herzlichen
dank für ihr zahlreiches kommen freue
mich sehr dass sie interesse daran haben
was meine fraktion die größte fraktion
im deutschen bundestag heute getan hat
sie hat einen fraktionsvorsitzenden
gewählt ich freue mich dass ich im amt
auch von der neuen fraktion wieder
bestätigt worden bin freue mich über das
große vertrauen empfinde das als ehre
und bin auch
sehr berührt über die wertschätzung
es ist eine große aufgabe insbesondere
weil wir uns einig darüber sind so
schnell wie möglich olaf scholz zum
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
zu wählen das ist etwas was wir auch mit
vielen menschen in deutschland teilen
egal wem sie am sonntag ihre stimme
gegeben hat für viele ist offensichtlich
dass die spd die partei ist die nicht
nur viele stimmen dazu gewonnen hat
sondern die den kanzlerkandidaten ein
großes vertrauen die dem
kanzlerkandidaten ein großes vertrauen
geschenkt haben uns jetzt in der lage
sein sollte eben mit diesem vertrauen
auch im kanzleramt mit erfahrung und
kompetenz entscheidungen zu treffen wir
wollen das als größte fraktion
ermöglichen möchte ich auch darüber in
kenntnis setzen dass wir eine sehr
interessante eine sehr lebhafte eine
sehr junge eine sehr diverse
spd-bundestagsfraktion mit insgesamt 206
abgeordneten haben das hat sich heute
morgen vielleicht auch im paul löbe aus
dem einen oder anderen offenbart ich bin
da sehr froh darüber und genau das hat
sich auch noch einmal bestätigt aus dem
wahlkampf wir haben sehr interessante
biographien in unserer fraktion zusammen
junge und ältere und das macht uns
glaube ich auch für die vier jahre so
stark
dank kommunizieren fragen der erste war
herr rittler
insbesondere rötlich sie haben es
angesprochen
die der osten die ostdeutschen
bundesländer wo die spd gerade auch am
sonntag wieder gezeigt hat dass sie dort
durchaus auch vertrauen genießt das
gerade auch junge abgeordnete die den
mut vor einem jahr gehabt haben den hut
in den ring zu werfen wo die
umfrageergebnisse ich fühle mich gerade
so waren dass man hoffte dann auch hier
im deutschen bundestag platz nehmen zu
dürfen
und das ist auch eine große chance die
die spd auch ergreifen muss im osten in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern wieder
vertrauen aufzubauen und da wächst ja
auch etwas in einer jungen generation
die wir auch hoffen in unserer fraktion
widerspiegeln zu können
nun das sind ja alles kluge neue
kolleginnen und kollegen die ja auch das
wahlergebnis lesen können sie sehen das
vielleicht dinge die der ein oder andere
mal erwogen hat aber ich bin mir gar
nicht so sicher ob sie so groß darüber
nachgedacht hat sondern die haben bis
sonntag über ihr wahlergebnis ihr
eigenes wahlergebnis zuerst mal
nachgedacht und dafür gekämpft sehen sie
eben das drei parteien
einen vertrauensvorschuss von vielen
bürgerinnen und bürgern bekommen haben
die auch eine fortschritts koalition
bilden können unter einem kanzler olaf
scholz das ist die spd das sind die
grünen und das ist die fdp und deswegen
sollten auch grüne und fdp klug genug
sein das angebot von uns jetzt bald
gespräche
sondierungen für eine koalition dann
auch zu führen auch ergreifen das ist
mir ganz wichtig und ich bin auch ganz
sicher das ist der wunsch auch von
vielen jungen kolleginnen und kollegen
in meiner fraktion
frau becker
hallo
also in der tat das ist immer noch mein
wunsch und auch unser angebots dass die
anderen die wir in einer solchen
fortschritts koalition sehen mit uns
diese gespräche führen sollten und wenn
ich von ende der woche gesprochen habe
bleiben dafür noch einige tage übrig
hier stehen zur verfügung wir wissen
nicht genau was eben auch im hinblick
auf das was gestern offensichtlich in
der cdu csu fraktion ja auch ein
bisschen zu unmut verwirrung neuen
zeiträumen bestimmt hat ob das zum
beispiel fdp und grüne noch mal
beeinflusst hat wir stehen bereits und
wir stehen verlässlich bereit
gibt es denn bereits hier auch nicht
aber in berlin ein gespräch schon vor
dem wochenende und das zweite werten sie
das treffen gestern abend von grünen und
fdp
ist dass man sie versorge das nur die
grünen atypischen fakten schaffen bevor
sie überhaupt mit den beiden ins
gespräch kommen nein wenn grüne und fdp
gestern sich getroffen haben so
interpretiere ich dass das diese beiden
parteien die beiden fraktionen
misstrauen abbauen müssen der eben von
vor vier jahren offensichtlich zwischen
beiden fraktionen zwischen beiden
parteien entstanden ist als sie es nicht
geschafft haben eine regierung zu bilden
und
ich kann ihnen nur
viel glück dabei wünschen misstrauen
abzubauen weil wir brauchen für ein land
was vor großen herausforderungen steht
verlässlichkeit vertrauen untereinander
wir wollen fdp und grünen auch dieses
vertrauen schenken und deswegen stehen
wir jederzeit zu ersten gesprächen über
eine zukünftige fortschritts koalition
auch zur verfügung
die kollegen haben es auch mehrfach
versucht gibt es denn schon kontakte von
grünen und fdp zur spd und in welcher
ausgangsposition befindet man sich
eigentlich als wahlsieger wenn der dritt
und viertplatzierte jetzt schon mal
vorher fakten schafft also sie wissen
ich mache keine sex mit mir reden habe
und zu selbst gemacht und wenn das
notwendig ist um andere davon zu
überzeugen belastbare gespräche zu
führen
dann soll es so sein aber auf der
anderen seite ich finde deutschland
braucht keine fotos sondern deutschland
braucht eine regierung die tatkräftig
auch die herausforderung annimmt wir
würden das gerne eben tun uns die
wählerinnen und wähler haben mit einem
deutlichen signal und insbesondere auch
jetzt in den nach befragungen werden aus
sicht der mehrheit der bundesbürgerinnen
und bundesbürger im kanzleramt gesehen
wird olaf scholz einen vertrauen
geschenkt und dafür wollen wir das jetzt
haut auch erarbeiten
sie sprachen hat eben schon vor dem
treffen von fdp und grünen haben sich
auch schon bewertet wie bewerten sie das
in hinblick auf ihre position in
späteren verhandlungen wenn die beiden
sich jetzt auf die dritte position
einigen schwächt das in gewisser weise
ihre verhandlungsposition das weiß ich
ja gar nicht ob sie sich einigen ich
glaube ja eher wie gesagt das misstrauen
was ich aufgebaut hat auch in den vier
jahren aber insbesondere bei den
erfolglosen koalitionsverhandlungen
damals mit der union dass sie versuchen
vielleicht das eine oder andere als was
als störung wahrgenommen wurde damals
eben nicht mehr aufkommen zu lassen
ich bin ganz zuversichtlich dass wir
auch in ruhe und letztlich eben auch mit
klaren überzeugungen über die
herausforderung für dieses land werden
reden können wir haben vorschläge wir
haben einen kompass und wir haben
insbesondere olaf scholz der kollege
unternehmen natürlich ja nicht schon
nach der wahl ist möglicherweise ja
schon wieder vor der wahl haben sie als
fraktionschef wenn schon eine kandidatin
einen kandidaten für das amt des
bundestagspräsidenten im kopf und können
sie uns an online also ich bin
ganz klar davon überzeugt dass die
tradition die hier im deutschen
bundestag immer so gehalten worden ist
dass die stärkste fraktion den
bundestagspräsidenten
oder eine bundestagspräsidentin zu
nominieren auch von den anderen
fraktionen mit respekt auch gesehen wird
und sie können sicher sein dass wir eine
starke kandidatin einen starken
kandidaten dafür nominieren und
gleichzeitig werden wir auch einen
weiteren vize präsidentin stellen
präsidenten auf
dieselbe frage wie gefällt ihnen denn
dass auch ihr name genannt wird oder
werden sie können sie sich das
vorstellen oder werden sie jetzt sagen
hört mal her ich bin jetzt mit fast 98
prozent fraktionschef geworden und ich
würde es auch bleiben wenn es eine
wertschätzung sein soll da sich genannt
werde freue ich mich darüber
es geht auch viel um die tonalität um
die frage auf welcher respekt ebene
begegnet man sich
ist es tatsächlich so dass man sich da
jetzt selbst ein bisschen zur saison
ruft und mögliche quertreiber oder im
spitzen gegen mögliche koalitionspartner
dann auch erstmal stumpf stellen will
inwiefern versuchen sie ja auch ein
bisschen ruhe reinzubekommen
der mich ein bisschen
beobachten wollte und konnte weiß dass
ich so gut wie möglich immer versuche
die ruhe zu bewahren und wenn ich damit
auch auf kolleginnen und kollegen
einwirken kann ist das nicht falsch weil
ich glaube die menschen wollen jetzt
kein spektakel
sie wollen kein winken vom balkon die am
ende nichts gutes bedeuten sondern sie
wollen eben auch belastbare gespräche
und die bieten wir an
vielen dank fragen wir dann wünsche ich
einen weiteren tag bin ich ihnen auch
und bitte bleiben sie gesund und
alles gute auf demnächst dankeschön